you
servant of one is awesome that's for
sure already we have an Eastern boulder
inna kicking off in just a few here we
go one hour of 1-minute chess
let's do it alright team wipe
mint for sure coming from asylum
no no we're gonna keep the tension
see six huh keeping this
and I'm gonna grab some space now
III wasn't just a
all waiting move
so where do we go from here contest the
a file
this guy
I'm threatening something sneaky I
believe
here comes the sneakiness
- unprotected queen
I want the bishop
and then flight square I don't like how
I play that
I think I could do this
right there I have rook b3
timely
how much time though
and finally I put pressure on that pawn
I want to go here just kind of control
some pawn breaks
have an extra pond
let's keep on expanding
what do I want to be
not sure
I better make some progress soon
I don't even see that they moved
oh boy
you
three seconds is not a lot
just want to push through
you
holy cow are you gonna commentate I'll
try if I have a few seconds I didn't
have a few seconds on that one I had
maybe a few hundredths of a second
oh man okay let's pick up a pond now
he's poison ooh
all right
add some queen a4 stuff going on
can I push that
I know coming after me
um let's just kind of shut it down some
I could take this pawn let's not fall
we're servant of one I'm not falling for
that move again
I'm not playing a very good game here
my queen on a different square dark
square Bishop Soph
now things should be beautiful
we're control
how am i rock enough for
check should not bother me
maybe I take the pawn now I like my
I like my rook too much all right sue me
I like my knight too much oh my god I
just dropped my rook this is gonna be
bad
yeah
this is bad and it's just gonna get
worse is what I mean
there was a moment as soon as I went on
the f7 square
okay let's just see and let's just track
this guy down
he's a little dangerous
and now we'll just throw them in a pin
and no stalemates
let's just get
last pond I know why I was sticking
there
no stalemates there we go back to
tournament okay
here we go
tribe III
and how about okay g3 Bishop g2 and u4
that's how we get this in successfully
and more than the are getting a fork
now night here to here is actually a
little bit of nine let's take the night
go here and then Castle queenside hmm
let's just defend this pawn Knight C 496
let's just break a pin knight on f3 this
actually looks pretty serious I didn't
mean to run it like that
I guess we'll take upon ninety six
I got a fork on now work on that square
I'm hitting both Brooks
I guess we'll take that one and I know
let's go here there's a queen check but
that shouldn't be any bother and now
they're in a tough spot I'm just gonna
pile up on the night
just keep that there
I have also queen bee five let's pile up
I don't know my queen to go too far
because there's Bishop takes pawn stuff
let's try this Bishop here it's the most
agree now they're just playing with the
Queen
now we're threatening a mate and one
actually too many too many good things
at that point back to terminal okay game
over bro
first there with ten I guess we'll try a
need for a game
um and I got I got to pace myself here
this is this is an hour long one use
just the half hours okay with h5 I'm
definitely seeking out the g5 square
let's immediately look to crack things
open let's take I'm not doing anything
with that recapture 96 I have but I
don't know I like my night as well as
Bishop check this is winning no matter
what
it's just Castle I feel like in this
position I just have to mobilize all my
pieces and it should be winning let's
try a check you know they have to go
into some odd pin hmm I don't like
giving up my dark square bishop but okay
o'night here would have been good what
am i doing just pile up on the pin
knight it realized it was hitting with
tempo I don't have any time
let's do it now no time back to
tournament okay 15 13 12 John wick is up
there
game over bro EEP lair 64 players in
here still plenty of time John wick
all right let's try that f6 interesting
move order for a black mare Timur
kingside castle huh take with the bishop
if I took with the night there's Bishop
check on Bishop check in this position
I'm fine with stepping up
we do next I'm not afraid of this check
just keep pushing
keep pushing I'll take with this one
isolated pawn I guess we'll get to the
second
whoo go here isn't that
to defend anyhow I gotta go very
defensive
I went upon if they try that and now I
have back rank trickery with this it's a
full rook here I go here
determent lands and I was ready to go my
instinct said go to d7 to attack e5 but
then I realized and my finger at Bishop
was pointing right at there and g2 point
okay um
stop knight here
I don't
take that let's try this eyeing Rand
2020 let's try for this maneuver
give me the dark
this is enormous this Bishop you cannot
say enough about him he is a monster
let's play on the Kings side this bishop
yeah he is he is worth so much okay
I just want to defend their threats
I can actually afford to do these
passive like moves because of this
superglue I don't know how you ever get
rid of that bishop meanwhile Knight to
g5 oh this is actually how they make
progress yeah this wasn't this wasn't
best what I did they could have played
the knight back home and I don't know
how I would have broken through now my
queen is going into pac-man mode
Wow she is hungry
let's go with this one no pressure on my
rook now
can't defend the rook
that guy he's the MVP
but he controlled the whole board
basically
okay Aurora
just 11 let's try c4
we have a center presence central
presence
dark squares
okay
here I have this
just want to pick up this pawn now
let's put the bishop here
and
on the Avon
take out the rooks
or take out the Queen how to move by
night next I think
wait a second he's short on squares
isn't he
I'll do this they have this move
I still have that move okay I guess I
could yes I could do what let's try this
don't like how I played these last
handful moves
not at all need to reposition my night
on their bishop
in-betweener no let them react to a
threat as their night trap yeah he's not
just go here push
they could have captured the night okay
they're in trouble actually I'm getting
the bishop they don't have these two
squares
glad I made that move
knife oh man
I was gonna say knifes my bishop our
knifes knives knives
criss-cross
all right let's
continue asking questions
step up so this is some kind of reverse
Dutch
that's not working
here oh I guess here and then here let's
just take out the night castle I should
have maybe done that move my Queens
ready to slip in though
getting one of them
to follow
I don't know why I'm doing this move
who felt wrote rate somehow
I have
attacks against the Queen
let's try this there's no long
much pressure here stink like this
pressure in here so clean here's a
threat how are they stopping this
I have that covered
so a7 is falling for mate back to
tournament yeah we got 28 with fire
Logan 5
let's try D 5
fianchetto for this game as well 96
should have 5 Knight to e4
back up try and say that he's out of
play this night is unprotected
that said I don't want this file to open
up okay let's jump in now
hmm
that was a bit awkward
centralized
that wasted a lot of time let's focus on
c4
five wanna cement my night in there I
have these ideas I'm on b4 now I missed
that
and let's just solidify my structure
and get ready to push my pond
he could be chased away let's try this
- blunder I would have been a terrible
blunder here's a fork let's go here
I don't have much time
I gotta go faster
I want pigs man gimme pigs crashing
through
pigs
give me the pigs man give me the pigs
so easy to pre move now
two seconds is plenty
here we go back to tournament land 32
with fire 29:23 21 14 change
okay
let's try knee for a game
Grand Prix
this is rare for me let's pin
let's damage the structure and then go
here castle
can't take twice on this square
all right this is very weakening
this is servant of one like tactics you
had to be there for the Simon to know
what I'm talking about I just gave up on
up for nothing
how do we call what I just did there
blunder upon whoa
straight-up blunder my queen let's go
after the king this should work because
I could take here and then take the rook
stubble up c6 is collapsing killer
discovery right around the corner double
check and mate got it back to tournament
king out to go forward but it was still
busted from there have the Queen of
minimum
36:29 25 under 40 90 are in here now
probably something close to 100 will
resign for beer
all righty let's try c5a benoni
a benoni it is Wow Mouse lip I think
they were trying to prevent Bishop to g4
I thought maybe that as a pawn sock
would have been good
I want to activate
take that pond take this one I want some
open files just jump in here
ready to jump in okay
where control this should be very good
all my pieces are slipping in now
[Music]
I'm gonna jump in here no no no no no oh
there's rook there I didn't see that
dropping stuff they have this now what
am i doing
I know I could take with the pun I'm not
seeing things very clearly
I want to be able to sack here and then
take here but the not not trade Queens
and now I could do this straightaway
where's the mate what's that about
let's check I have that move there also
that time um that got a little too a
little too complicated more complicated
than I would have liked all right
still on streak here
who's next
the man the man the man is next it's
throwing the bird my way he's pinned
alright let's just take away one of
their squares
I'll go Queen side as well
yeah
I don't like my dark squares
kill the bishop and centralize I want
this square
nightlife squared Bishop should be
pretty good
take like this now there I mean there's
two very good pieces that would be good
here let's go here stop the night let's
take him out
here to control the I want to safeguard
my king and somehow get my knight here
let's just keep it closed
this
the plan
if I get that in it's very very good
over there and now it's locked over here
so I could play on the other wing
I will be able to break something open
taking what the pawn is good as well
let's keep the tension I'll take oh I
want I wanted to go with the other one
I'll go with the pawn I can step up with
my king he could move in any time as
well
taken with the rook undermining this
structure now good take here get this
pawn next I got checks they're down on
time they needed they needed to do
anything to stop my knight from getting
on that blockading square once that was
established then has complete control
secured my Bishop no night there they're
preparing a five they're gonna get e5
let's just go here see if I could go and
do some weaknesses defend my Bishop oh
let's try this getting a little fancy
now just a little fancy I wouldn't mind
having my Bishop flushed on the same
diagonal as the Queen
he's unprotected now so this kind of
stuff is in the air let's put it on
right now
I could have captured that pun let's
back up
there's a pin going on here ah man
let's take and I don't take with the
Queen let's go here get into the d6
square he spins centralize and I flushed
me away my knight is out of play they
have a weak King
f6 gotta go here yeah they're gearing up
for this move alright my Queens gonna
drop back let's secure my knight
actually we are the time okay
they're going to get the exchange
I have a really strong night though
really strong night discoveries
unavoidable
you
you
oh man John wick is fast 48 I got that
one on the clock
fortunately I had a pesky night
why did I have compensation well
when they won the exchange they won it
in a way where they gave up their better
Bishop so that's why they're why merged
with a a monster night
so iqp position
and soon they're gonna be going after h7
very soon right now soon
coming under some heavy fire
let's take once this is very difficult
to defend
I want to hunt like Bishop here
oh I had Bishop there before totally
missed that I had that move what my
night to drop back his defense a lot of
the dark squares this working close to
working could take here barely barely
take their that
I took a lot of time
oh just dropped a piece there where's my
clock by the way
and
you
holy cow
that guy was flying ah man
those are tough to lose
being up all that material but yeah it
took too much time ah man
I had Bishop to e4 he had 17 seconds
left Wow
okay well now I know if we get paired up
again and I imagine we will I gotta kick
it up a notch or two or three okay
noted
I'm just letting the night get in there
too easily John wick again on board
don't like home playing this
hmm I'm the rook in the night mm-hmm
now that's a fancy move that's that
works now I want my knight right here
let's go here and I want
[Music]
I want to get rid of their night first
ok now I'll go for this no I don't have
worry about that kind of stuff also this
is a threat I want to see this before
that move came in
let's just break it open now
the king
let's check check probably check my way
to winning this
pick up some pawns
pushing keep pushing
I have a flight square that's me back
determine okay I got fifteen fifty
thirty nine thirty less than twenty
eight left
game over bro in what up yo dog here we
go I gotta go faster
let's try French
okay so we're going to end up with a
similar structure I guess
all righty
really going after my throat here what
did I do to deserve this
let's take him out
all right let's try to break it up a
little bit
it's okay y'all didn't beat wiener
yeah let's try that
no bishop there we got a rockier stuff
let's take once let's take here actually
oh my god
totally missed that
nothing I could do about it
like honor
ah man
repetition
can I return the favor I have anything
good if I take here the bishop pair I
just want to I just want to do what yeah
there is that isn't there here's 17
seconds again back determined oh my god
after B takes c3 there's Bishop a to the
very thing that I was pointing out one
like a couple moves earlier ah man I got
got me again
that was a mouse lip okay
ah I liked both of my
- against what up your dog
all right let's jump on in there go
after h7 oh why not well actually let's
try with the night first let me sneak in
here on the rook I feel like I don't
even want the rook
I want the mates we got the mates I
close by
this has to work come on h7 with the
bishop
that's check-in
has to block I had a sense that that
night was worth more than the rook
that's why I didn't want to just go
right in and go in for the exchange all
right let's try see for a game a
grünfeld
okay
I got a secure d4 it's gonna come under
some heavy fire here we go
getting getting a piece now hitting the
night in the queen let's see if I could
avoid losing the Queen
get castled Queen on c4 e6
and take let's go here 85 next rip to d7
d 7
take with check night here is a main
threat very diff
got to defend no defense just take care
get rid of the bishop he's very good and
they resigned back to tournament
okay fifty four forty two thirty eight
twenty two minutes left about ten or ten
or eleven games remaining
let's see somebody anybody
perché Rosen all right hmm I guess d6
and stay out of my F pawns way okay I
was thinking I could push here maybe
maybe I still I'll still try for that
before I commit now the bishops dead
clean exchange
stop night here
I'm almost ready to allow a night to go
in there again it's happening
I ain't here to here hmm not playing
well why
backed up castle don't take upon take
another I could take it's okay to take a
free piece I don't know why I didn't do
that
jump up in here it's
fancy now discoveries let's get all my
pieces playing
right here that one hurts that one
definitely hurts
there in a pin
alright where's the mate there it is
got the bishop there I'll allow their
pawns to get to I don't know they're
just a bit of a tsunami of pawns there
in the center
what up your dog has been on a tear
these lasts seven eight games I'm
definitely still catchable here 58 and
he just finished we have another one
here what do we what do we throw at this
guy he five
all right
I feel like they don't want it yeah
they're not they're not the castling
type
they're definitely not the castling type
hey wait for me to Castle kingside
that's the plan
I'll take the pawn and regret it
after
Wow I just I just spent so much time I
got to go into a prevent here
Wow
d efense oh my god
so fast cleanest queen is close to dead
that's why they pause there for a second
their Queens cooked and not anymore
just defend everything
you
why not go two steps
you
we got the mates man we got the mates we
got the mates man the old RB special
right there Queen to H one we got the
mates under-18 I needed that one he was
on fire he needed to be extinguished oh
man I was once again way down on the on
the tank
he had so much so much gas he's been
having us so much gas me one we got the
mate
h2 what's happened to gear we got the
mates Bishop h7 normally that the that
isn't me but what a night in the corner
something special happens a mater oniy
under 1766 with fire 48 game over bro
right on my heels oh really
I got 18 I'm up 18 throw the care out
there fianchetto
only chess players know that lingo right
only chess players
okay open up the e-file
we do this first okay I should still
have compensation a sink in here I think
takes pawn we do that
let's take him slanted check and come on
there should be juicy now let's just do
this this night could be flushed away at
any point
any point student now I could have
captured
[Music]
it's from my bishop somewhere else let's
do this
I'm getting fancy let's try that
um I guess the Queen's are going to come
off
uh can I make up my mind still in a pin
oh and he's not an append anymore I
still like my like my bishops that
wasn't planned I'm not going to take
kind of keep their night under control
the night is gonna be out of control oh
good it's scary I didn't realize that
that was check please exchange
you
oh my god point 1 9 I'll take it oh man
so lucky so so lucky
oh man did I spoil a wonderful
middlegame position Wow how did I let it
get to that point should have never
never got to that point
we're gonna set up accelerated fishing
pole action they defended it I don't
know why I still went in for that Queeny
4 is still pretty serious I'll take and
then try this structure I could have
grabbed him too
I guess I don't want
mmm I'll go here I'll take them if I
have another chance hey five okay it's
time for him to go
h5 in the old over
the oldrover centralized castle by hand
there we go
Bishop takes h6 sneaky pins back up and
now we're looking for this night to h5
was better let's do it
Queen h5
come on move your queen what are you
waiting for
make it one threat oh that one's painful
74 with fire sixty fifty we haven't been
paired up yet
game over bro
all right let's
right I'll take that this guy is flying
hmm okay
a lot covered we're going for the
minority attack
mm-hmm it's hanging under that pond
let's back up 'if I've defend here
centralized in the knee five no he five
right now one double one of my pawns
Queen here soon and how do I want to
recapture will keep the structure
maybe a bit premature
because I'd be undermining no no no no
no I'll take it like this and I'll take
with the pawn now that's a bit more
simplified
I have f4 actually can I win this let's
let's try it two bishops versus the rook
it's going to take some work
command King
I want their kingdom of oh this is gonna
this is going to be tough
are we almost there yet
I went after I wanted
giving me a pond now
pawn here pins
oh I just wanted a piece
why do they do that
oh man
why did I allow that
ah man
76 68 a draw
Baelfire that's the bit okay this is a
big game he is right back in there if he
gets the W second place guy game over
bro
already not our first time maybe one the
first time is playing while I'm running
a stream let's focus on e4
and one more okay that's a pawn pack all
the way up let's push these guys gotta
watch out for tricky mates
tricky mates
hmmm let's give a check I forgot
could do that
yeah okay what about this move next
boy
in trouble I am in trouble
you
look at my time as well oh boy this
one's a goner this one's a goner
hmm
ah and the time as well well it's gonna
be a close one towards the end I'm still
up for barely hanging on
76 72-54 no idea how this one's gonna
finish okay he is on a tear - how many
is that six in a row
I got to get back on fire
ah man why'd I have to lose the exchange
all right this is this is fun man this
is fun who's not having fun I meant to
vote my night there can I get a fork no
maybe we glue a bishop in there again
like in that one game here we go let me
take like this and then go here okay
this pond should be a serious serious
thorn let's go here here and then put my
knight enough for now I had the bishop
as well
this is still winning for sure got the
night I'm on the rook and this rook is
imprisoned he's never coming out
Mayon to back to tournament okay we got
the w-who what up your dog
I gotta go faster that's all there is to
it
kind of put the foot on the I can't I
can't talk difficulty talking again take
me Bishop takes Knight now ah
let's throw the night in there I'll
castle this way and reposition my night
okay you need to go somewhere else man
their night is struggling so is their
Bishop so is the so is their whole
queenside let's open it up
oh how did I allow that night to jump in
there
this is unbelievable what's happening
right here
oh my god
this counter place should have never
ever happened ever
gotta get rid of their night
you
they're being sneaky man just get rid of
that oh they were in pre move I needed
that
you
oh my god I was trying not I was trying
to do anything but give stalemate
and I gave stalemate and he just
overtook me we're gonna get paired up oh
oh is this one for the marbles or is it
for the marbles it's for the marbles
holy cow why
man
never ever ever happened ever oh that
was so awful so awful
oh boy just take some material right
okay come on now come on
if you can't win this geez
come on you have Forks back to
tournament
okay it's still closed
I think that yeah that's probably good
strategy what they just did there um is
he going to bruiser --q are you bruiser
Caen are you preserving is this a good
thing probably not a good thing that I
look what's uh let's just play regular
not a good opponent berserk anyhow come
on let's give check yeah they might be
preserving I gotta just focus on this
game right nothing I could do about that
one
let's jump in here I got Forks we got
Forks Inbetweeners Inbetweeners they're
gonna take my rook I gotta take that
I'll take this let's take there with
check and take the knight
give me some exchanges man right here
clean check right here get this reply
now our is the mate bishop flock
here we go
so there's no there's no time left I
gotta get this win
go up yeah so help me oh please don't
finish now he got you he didn't berserk
he didn't preserve he might be in
another game though he's not in another
game ten nine eight come on I need this
confetti
it's important three two one no
buzzer-beaters there it is oh it wasn't
it wasn't squeaky clean that's for sure
but I'll take the confetti as ugly as it
came 151 and I'll a nail-biter 83 82 62
yeah nice having this these guys in
there smacking me around ah man makes
for an exciting tournament that's for
sure very cool
alright let's see all the pages two
three four and who else was in there
awesome an awesome game over bro what up
your dog GG's
almost there
okay just by a hair one-point edge see
the 150 of you good games all
you